hey everybody my name is marina and i'll
be talking about adaptive massively
parallel constant round tree contraction
so tree contraction is a general process
for solving a large number of problems
on trees
so given a problem p in a tree t the
idea is basically to find a process to
iteratively contract components of t
until t becomes a single vertex this
contraction process must have must have
two different properties the first
property is the contraction must be
efficient and reversible so efficiency
is obviously important
reversibility is also important for
solutions that require
construction on the entire tree so once
you
find the the solution on the single
vertex after contraction we still have
to reverse the process to figure out how
it looks on the entire tree
in addition um as we do this contraction
process when we contract a component
we're going to be labeling the new
vertex that i was contracted into with
data
that kind of describes something
important about the original tree we
just compressed that data of course must
be space efficient so that we can keep
it
stored efficiently in parallel
and it also must be sufficient to
reconstruct the solution to the original
problem of the original tree
so this just basically means we don't
want to lose too much information to be
able to solve the initial problem as we
contract
um so this method was first introduced
by miller and reef in 1985. they found a
pram algorithm where pram is parallel
random access memory um it's a model of
distributed computation that's kind of
probably what you
imagine when you think of parallel
computation it's just a bunch of like
processors that can do individual
computations in parallel
so this algorithm that was in pram
requires o of login depth
which is basically a measurement of time
we call it rounds here because we're
going to
um
we're going to relate it to a round
complexity and another another model
computation now while we know that these
complexities aren't directly
analogous
the reason we compare them is because
they are both measurements of
communication so the number of pram
rounds is effectively how many times
processors need to communicate so in
this algorithm they need to communicate
o of login time and our goal is going to
be to reduce that amount of
communication in a different model
so this pram algorithm has been improved
upon multiple times but they all still
require login rounds
the algorithm has also been extended to
a number of different applications
including circuit evaluation finding
planar graph separators approximating
tree width and
that kind of thing
okay so let's talk about how the
algorithm itself works
we're going to be using the example of
expression evaluation where you're given
a mathematical expression you'd like to
evaluate and specifically the expression
in the top right
so if we want to solve this using tree
contractions we first have to represent
it as a tree
so the way we do this is we put all the
values at the leaves and then we
construct the tree going up based off of
the order of operations you put the
operators according to which you would
apply first
and in order to solve this tree we apply
create tree
contractions so
tree contractions run in a number of
phases and each phase consists of two
stages
so the first stage is going to be
compress in compress what the original
algorithm does is it contracts every
other vertex with exactly one child into
its parent so
we have this notion of a chain a chain
is a stick within a tree a long chain of
parents with one child with one child
with one child and so on and as we can
see in our tree we have a quite long
chain and what we do is we take every
other vertex on this chain and contract
it into its parent
so when we do this we obviously get rid
of some vertice vertices but we don't
want to lose the information from those
vertices so
when we contract two vertices what we're
going to do is we're going to store
on that vertex the new function that is
the composition of those two functions
so for instance when we contract the
negation into the inverse operator we
get this new function g of x which is
negative x to the negative first
similarly when we contract the negation
into the division operator we get f of x
y which is a binary function um which is
negative x over y so we apply the
negation to the first argument
okay so that's how compress works
in rake we simply contract all leaves
into their parents which looks something
like this
in this example
rake consists of
inputting arguments into functions so we
replace two plus three with five and we
input three into the second argument of
f to yield f prime which is just going
to be negative x over three it's now a
unary operator
and we can imagine continuing continuing
this process until we complete
and we find our answer for the
evaluation of the expression at the end
um now this
uh problem doesn't actually require
reversibility because we can just find
the solution in the final vertex
however a related problem is
sub-expression evaluation where we want
to take all sub-expressions within the
expression and find their value for
instance we would also want to know what
2 plus 3 is and what negative 2 plus 3
is what the inverse of that is and so on
um in order to do that we do need to
reverse the process so that we can find
the value at each note in the tree
because each node in this tree
corresponds to each sub-expression
i'm not going to discuss how to do that
but like there's some bookkeeping you
can do
to make sure that this process is
reversible so i just wanted to point
that out
okay
uh one more thing i'd like to talk about
with regard to this algorithm is why it
takes o of log n phases
so
to do this um we're going to be talking
about two different examples of trees on
either extreme so the first extreme tree
is going to be a
single stick tree so you have n vertices
that are all in a stick
um rake obviously doesn't do much
because you can only remove one vertice
vertex at a time if we break the leaves
compress however if we just apply
compress over and over again um each
time we apply compress every other
vertex will be contracted into its
parent thus reducing the size of the
tree by half thus we only require o of
log n
phases to be able to compress the tree
into a single vertex
on the other hand if we have a complete
binary tree
rake is very useful because
about half the vertices are leaves and
if we get rid of all the leaves we
divide the size of the tree by two and
thus it'll only take um o vlog and time
to rank and then if you have any kind of
intermediate tree just imagine uh having
a kind of combined argument of these two
things such that compress and rake
together uh can solve the tree
in overlogging phases and so that's the
basic gist of this algorithm
and again we're going to be trying to
improve the communication complexity of
this algorithm by looking to another
model of computation
and that model specifically is going to
be adaptive massively parallel
computation
so this is also known as ampc it is the
successor model distributed computation
to massively parallel computation or mpc
many of you may know this mpc is a
rather popular framework or model for
distributed computation
it's received a lot of attention in the
past like 10 or so years
and it generalizes a lot of popular
frameworks like mapreduce and things
like that
so it's a very popular model adaptive
massively parallel computation was
introduced just a few years ago very new
still a lot is unknown about this um
but yeah for those of you who are
familiar with mpc ampc is just a
slightly stronger version of mpc um it
can solve things more efficiently and uh
it's also highly practical given um how
commodity hardware hardware works okay
so in ampc we start with the input being
stored on a distributed hash table h
naught so what is a distributed hash
table just think of it as a very large
data structure that we can store stuff
on
where we can have parallel access to it
so even when we're doing parallel
computation where uh machines aren't
allowed to communicate with each other
um they are allowed to access this
distributed hash table um which is like
really the main difference between
adaptive massively parallel computation
and mpc
is the access to this uh in round
distributed hash table
and we'll see why this is stronger
okay
so ampc procedures um execute in rounds
and in each round
you're allowed to read from the previous
distributed hash table and write to the
next one so notice this doesn't mean you
can send messages to any other machine
in any tricky way because you're all
reading from the same thing and writing
to a different thing um
and so obviously this proceeds in some
number of rounds and then in the final
distributed hash table we have to output
our solution
okay so comparing this to mpc you could
rewrite this model to
be basically what mpc is if you don't
allow in-round read and write access to
distributed hash tables if you require
you first to read then to do the
parallel computation and then to write
to the next hash table if you do it
sequentially like that it becomes mpc
um so what power does this does this
give us well um oftentimes in
distributed computation what we want to
do
is store
a vertex on a machine as well as its
entire neighbor as well as its
neighborhood to be able to do like a
kind of local search
um so an npc you can you can do that you
swerve vertex on machine you look at its
neighborhood and then to get the two hop
neighborhoods you need to do a round of
communication to look at all your
neighbors and get the the next um hop of
your neighborhood however in ampc you
could actually execute a different kind
of search a depth first search right so
an ampc you take one vertex you can
query its neighbor on this distributed
hash table and then do that the same
thing for that vertex you can query its
neighbor and another neighbor and so on
so you can't do that in npc but in ampc
you can implement depth first search
which is a very unique thing that ampc
can do
so that's the kind of difference um
uh ampc uh breaks the one versus two
cycle conjecture that it can solve
connectivity
in um o of one rounds whereas in npc you
cannot do that
or it's conjectured that you cannot do
that
now let's talk about complexities so in
ampc we often look at problems on graphs
with n vertices and m edges obviously in
our case we're looking at trees so we're
going to be looking at n edges
uh we have three main complexities of
interest uh the most important one
usually is the round complexity it's
often what we optimize for
generally we want this to be something
like sub-logarithmic for most problems
um obviously the gold standard is going
to be constant um in terms of n
and uh this is what we actually will end
up achieving in our algorithms
um so ram complexity is what we're
mainly focusing on
we also have memory which is the local
space of each machine during the
distributed computation
this is going to be o of n to the
epsilon for a fixed epsilon between zero
and one so epsilon is going to be viewed
as more or less a constant but we do
kind of want to optimize for like
dependent any dependency on epsilon
note that this is strictly sublinear
this is what we consider the low memory
regime
um
so what that means is that if you have a
vertex and you want to store its entire
neighborhood uh you can't actually do
that because it might have up to n minus
one vertices whereas we only have o of n
to the epsilon space which is smaller
than that
so um
that makes this uh regime of ampc much
more difficult to work with and you have
to find tricky ways to solve this
the final space we consider often is uh
the total space um which is basically
how much total storage we have going on
at a single time so it doesn't
necessarily consider like the entire
history of the distributed hash tables
um but we want to make sure that any
distributed hash table we're considering
plus all the space taken up by all of
the processors is that most linear in
the problem size size i just view this
as more of a sanity check to make sure
we're not really blowing up the space
complexity
given some input
but again round complexity is the one
we're usually optimizing for and the
memory is also something that's very
important to be aware of
okay
so this is
uh
the complexities of interest
okay now let's look at some known uh low
memory ampc algorithms that we will both
use and compare our results to
so the ones we'll be using are as
follows rooting orienting pre-order
numbering and connectivity on forests
these all have been shown to be able to
be run in o of one over epsilon ampc
realms
whereas by the one versus two cycle
conjecture
they take uh at least o of log n and pc
rounds or at least we believe that to be
the case
um so obviously if we want to implement
our algorithms efficiently and we're
using these functions we need to
implement them in ampc over mpc
our results
include two algorithms the first is
going to be only on trees of bounded
degree that is the maximum degree in the
tree is at most and the epsilon where
recall that epsilon is our local memory
parameter
so uh we get an o of one over epsilon
squared round tree contraction algorithm
entries of bounded degree
and on general trees it becomes o 1 over
epsilon cubed
now the first result is both used as a
subroutine in our main result and also
can be applied independently to problems
we'll actually show that some problems
can be solved on unbounded degree trees
if we first do a transformation to
similar problems on bounded degree trees
okay
now let's look at our results and
compare them to existing ampc algorithms
so the first two we'll be looking at is
maximal matching and maximal independent
set so for both of these we show that
they can be solved in o of one over
epsilon squared rounds using our first
algorithm because they can be translated
into
problems on bounded degree trees
now we don't actually beat existing
algorithms because there exist constant
round algorithms that solve both of
these problems however we think this is
a really interesting strategy that may
be able to be used to solve other
problems using our more efficient
algorithm on bounded degree trees
so that's just like a a quick result for
our first algorithm our second algorithm
is where we get some of the truly novel
applications
so first maximum cardinality matching uh
we can solve a oneplus epsilon
approximate maximal matching algorithm
in o of log log n a and pc rounds by a
previous result from about a year ago
um and we can do this using our
algorithms in constant rounds and find
an optimal solution of course the caveat
here is that we can only do this on
trees but nevertheless it's an entirely
novel result
maximum weighted matching had a similar
result but it was only a two plus
epsilon approximation and we can also
improve this to get the same result on
trees
maximum weighted independent sent to our
knowledge has not been explored in ampc
so we get the first result which is 1
over epsilon cubed rounds on trees and
this is also optimal
finally true isomorphism is also a
problem we do not believe has been
explored in ampc and we get a first
constant time
algorithm
okay so this is our results uh now we
can get into some of our actual methods
so the first algorithm we'll talk about
is the algorithm on bounded degree trees
so require recall that tree contractions
require two stages compress and rake so
we will start by describing describing
the compressed stage
so in the compressed stage what we're
going to do is instead of contracting
every other vertex in a chain into its
parent we're going to be contracting
larger components of a tree um into a
single vertex and this will allow us to
get much more efficient contraction
processes
um the way we do this is we do it
according to what we call a pre-order
decomposition so a pre-order
decomposition takes in two parameters
beta and k
k defines how we're going to partition
it so we're partitioning the graph into
what we call k groups
these groups have to agree with the
pre-order traversal and by that i mean
the first vertex in the pre-order
traversal must be in the first partition
and any subsequent vertex
must be in either the same partition as
the previous vertex in the pre-order
traversal or the next partition the next
group sorry
um additionally we have this parameter
beta which
ensures some guarantee about the size of
these groups so specifically for each
group if we sum the degree of all the
vertices in the group we wanted this to
be bounded by beta and as we might see
later um this is basically to ensure
that the size
um
of any anything we need to store on this
partition as we compress it will not
exceed our machine space so beta is
going to basically be controlling the
the local space of our algorithm
okay now let's talk about how
compression actually uses this
so
to compress we
track connected components induced by
each group why can't we contract each
group entirely while they might not be
entirely connected
so let's look at the example here on the
left it's a tree and we label each
vertex with the group it is in so the
first group is actually quite nice
because it's entirely connected so we
can contract that vertex or that
group into a single vertex as we see on
the right
however group two consists of only
isolated vertices so when we do this
contraction process we don't actually
reduce this group at all in fact we get
three individual vertices in the
resulting graph
now this might seem like this is
something that makes the computation too
difficult to perform but we actually
show that this exhibits a number of nice
properties that we can leverage to get
an efficient algorithm so what are the
properties
the first property if beta is greater
than or equal to the degree of any
vertex in the graph we can find a
decomposition such that the number of
groups is at most o of n over beta
now note that the beta parameter
constraint here is just to make sure
that the periodic decomposition is
possible if there exists a vertex whose
degree is greater than beta then it
can't exist in any partition right
because otherwise we would violate the
beta constraint so that's just what we
mean by beta must be greater than equal
to the max degree in the tree
um
and this just ensures that we have some
sort of bound on the number of groups in
our decomposition
the other um
the other property we have is that after
compression we know there will be at
most one internal node per group and
this comes from the fact that we based
it off of the pre-order traversal so if
you consider a group and you look at all
connected components induced by that
group
every single connected component except
the last one will contain all of its
descendants that is necessary by the
properties of the pre-order traversal so
when that component is contracted it
will be a leaf that's the only non-leaf
that can exist after we do this um for a
single group must be the the last
connected component and that is
something that can be really vital to
our argument going forward
okay so what we have is we know there
are k internal nodes after compression
and k equals o of n over beta
to rake what we're going to do is
contract all leaves into their parents
pretty simple
so this is what our entire process looks
like we compress and then we break
so if we let beta equal n to the epsilon
which again is our local space
constraint
um we can show that well if there are k
internal nodes and k is at most n over
beta which is n to the one minus epsilon
um they're only
n to the one minus epsilon internal
nodes after compression we remove all
the leaves and that's all that's left in
the tree therefore the final tree will
only have o of one o of n to the one
minus epsilon vertices if we continue
repeating this until we can fit it on
one machine this will only take o of one
over epsilon phases now each phase
actually requires o of one over epsilon
rounds because we have to do a pre-order
traversal and if we recall that requires
o of one of our epsilon
phases an ampc at least to our current
knowledge
therefore this algorithm as it is
requires of one over epsilon squared
rounds and can solve tree contractions
on bounded degree trees
so this is a quite nice result um i
won't talk about how to reverse it it's
just again a matter of bookkeeping
basically um but yeah it allows us to do
uh tree contractions on boundary degree
trees and constant rounds specifically
of one over epsilon squared rounds
okay
now we're going to talk about how to do
this on higher degree trees
so the hardest part about handling high
degree trees is the high degree of
vertices so naturally the first thing
we're going to do when we compress is
temporarily get rid of the high degree
vertices
specifically we're going to pick some
threshold alpha
and any vertex with degree at least
alpha is going to be removed temporarily
what we get when we do this is a forest
of
components of small degree so we can
just in parallel on each tree in the
forest we run our previous algorithm
which takes o of one of our epsilon
squared rounds to contract that tree
into a single vertex
okay so we've already leveraged our
previous algorithm
and after we contracted them into single
vertices we put back in the high degree
vertices and connect them to the
appropriate small components
we call this resulting tree a big small
tree because it consists of two types of
vertices the first type is a high degree
vertex i.e a big vertex and the other is
a vertex that represents a
connected component of small degree
vertices that was uh contracted into a
single vertex and this is what we call a
small component
so this process can be represented like
this um the tree on the left consists of
a bunch of small components um
highlighted in red we contract them into
single vertex vertices ignoring the high
degree vertices that we removed and we
get the following tree on the right so
the high degree vertices in the big in
the tree on the right um are going to be
the white ones and the ones that are
shaded in red are these small component
vertices
just like before this exhibits a number
of properties that we can leverage to
get our results
so the first property actually is quite
simple the first we just
we simply observe that no small
component is the parent of another and
this is just by the maximality of the
connected components we're contracting
if a small component is the parent of
another small component
then they would have just been
contracted into the same component in
this second bullet of this process
and this um with some uh
more complicated arguments allows us to
show that after compression at least an
alpha over alpha plus four fractions of
the vertices are leaves this is a very
high fraction therefore when we rake
it's going to be quite nice
i will defer to the paper for more
details on this
okay
so
what we've seen is that we can show that
at least an alpha over alpha plus 4
fraction of the vertices are leaves
therefore there are only o of n over
alpha internal nodes remaining
when we rake we simply contract
contractual leaves into their parents
okay and we get something that looks
like this
based off of the same arguments we had
before if we let alpha equal n to the
epsilon so that everything works out um
we can see that the final tree will have
o of n to the one minus epsilon vertices
um and we can repeat this o of one over
epsilon times until it can fit on a
single machine
so this again will take o of one over
epsilon phases just like before um
however in each phase we have to call
our previous algorithm which took o of
one over epsilon squared
rounds therefore the final algorithm
takes o of one over epsilon cubed rounds
okay so this is going to be our final
result it's a constant round algorithm
for tree contraction on general trees
however there is one thing i've swept
under the rug and that is how rake works
so in the previous algorithm on boundary
degree trees rake was pretty simple
right we have
each vertex will have at most end to the
epsilon leaf children so
um you can store a vertex and all of its
leaf children on a single machine and
then contract it in one round in
parallel
um however in this case we might have
some problems because a vertex might
have um up to n leaves
and leaf children so we can't store all
those on one machine so raking is not as
trivial in this case
so now we'll briefly discuss how to
handle this and we do this with
something we call
sibling contraction
so say we have a vertex v and has and v
has over n to the epsilon children
then what we're going to do is we're
going to take this starting tree that is
just v and its uh leaf children
um and we're going to expand it into an
end to the epsilon area tree
specifically a complete and to the
epsonary tree so every vertex is going
to have um n to the epsilon children as
long as they can except the final one
might have fewer
it's going to look something like this
i've represented it as a binary tree but
you can imagine
its end to the epsilon area
okay specifically the way this tree is
mapped into this other tree is that the
root is mapped to the root and the
leaves are mapped to the leaves so the
only leaves sorry the only vertices
we're adding are all the internal nodes
except for the root okay everything else
is like a real vertex in our original
graph
and all we're going to do is we're going
to just sequentially rake all the leaves
at a certain layer in parallel so
since it's end of epsilon area every
vertex has at most end to the epsilon
children so we can store a vertex and
all of its children on a single machine
and rake all the leaves
um at once
okay so
if we just do this until we get to the
root then we've contracted the entire
tree into a single vertex um since the
height of this tree is o of one over
epsilon because it's n to the epsilon
area
this will require at most o of one over
epsilon parallel rake iterations
therefore this can be done in o of one
over epsilon rounds um which is even
faster than the compressed stage so this
does
applying this at each rake does not
actually um increase the asymptotic
complexity of our algorithm
now this seems like a nice simple way to
do this
but i will say this doesn't come without
a cost so
when we want to prove that a problem can
be solved using tree contractions we
would like to only have to show that we
can take a connected component and
contract it into a single vertex and
still label that vertex with enough
information to solve the problem on the
initial tree without blowing up the
space
that is ideally all we would have to
show but now given this is how we're
handling the the vertices we also have
to show that we can
handle expanding the tree and creating
these dummy vertices that won't mean
anything and then contracting them into
back into their parent so this is
actually a different thing to show and
as an is additional work that you have
to do
um to show that a problem can be solved
using tree contractions so it is an
unfortunate consequence of our methods
um but at least so far we don't see a uh
another solution to doing this
that would be an open question
um so yeah this completes our algorithm
and thus we've shown how to do constant
round tree contractions uh in ampc and
it solves a large range of problems i
obviously don't have time to get into
the applications they are actually quite
interesting and
sometimes they can be quite involved
it's not trivial to show a problem can
be solved using tree contractions
so
um yeah that is the presentation uh
thank you for listening i'd like to
thank my co-authors and all previous
authors of related works
as well as of course the
people organizing this conference thank
you